Als nächstes zeige ich dir,
wie du in Adobe Illustrator mit Ebenen arbeitest.
Vielleicht hast du schon mal mit Photoshop oder mit InDesign
gearbeitet, da ist es ähnlich, da gibt es auch Ebenen,
aber im Adobe Illustrator gibt es noch mal ein paar
Unterschiede, also selbst wenn du das schon kennst,
lohnt es sich, hier noch mal reinzuschauen.
Ebenen funktionieren eigentlich wie Schichten.
Also es ist, als ob du ein Platt Papier hast und auf dieses
Platt Papier noch ein weiteres darüber legst.
Das hilft dir, deine Zeichnung übersichtlich zu halten.
Um mit Ebenen zu arbeiten,
suchen wir jetzt erst mal das Ebenen Bedienfeld,
das findest du normalerweise hier rechts.
Falls du es aber jetzt gar nicht sehen solltest,
kann es sein, dass es irgendwo versteckt ist Vielleicht
kannst du dich erinnern, das Menü Fenster dient dazu,
Bedienfelder zu aktivieren oder zu deaktivieren.
Also falls du das Ebenen Bedienfeld jetzt nicht sehen
solltest, dann geh mal in das Menü Fenster und schau ob es
angeklickt ist.
Also Ebenen und da soll ein Häkchen dran sein.
Wenn das Häkchen jetzt dran ist und du das nicht siehst,
das Ebenen Bedienfeld,
dann ist es irgendwo versteckt auf deinem Bildschirm.
guck mal, ob du es irgendwo entdeckst.
Falls nicht,
kannst du einfach in dem Menü Fenster die Ebenen
deaktivieren, also das Häkchen wegmachen,
in dem du draufklickst und dann nochmal draufklicken.
Dann ist es wieder aktiviert und sollte irgendwo aufkloppen.
Jetzt gehen wir zu diesem Feld und als nächstes wollen wir
verstehen, wie man mit diesen Ebenen arbeitet.
Standardgemäß siehst du erstmal eine einzige Ebene und
die ist im Adobe Illustrator im Vergleich zu den anderen
Programmen mit einer Farbe hinterlegt und hier ist es immer
blau.
Deswegen ist auch deine Form die du jetzt gezeichnet hast,
du sie auswählst, blau.
Wenn du jetzt hier unten auf das Pluszeichen klickst,
dann wird eine neue Ebene angelegt.
Das ist jetzt deine zweite Ebene und da siehst du schon,
die hat eine andere Farbe, die ist jetzt rot.
Die dritte ist dann grün und dann kommen immer mehr
Farben dazu.
Das hilft dir,
das Ganze übersichtlich zu halten und dich zu orientieren.
Jetzt ist aber zum Beispiel die vierte Ebene auch eine Art
blau und relativ schwer von der ersten zu unterscheiden.
Das heißt wenn du jetzt hier die Farbe ändern möchtest,
kannst du einfach auf dieses weiße Kästchen drücken und es
öffnet sich ein Feld, wo du die Farbe ändern kannst.
Jetzt am Anfang arbeiten wir aber eigentlich nicht mit
so vielen Ebenen und generell brauchen wir für technische
Zeichnung jetzt auch nicht ganz so viele Ebenen.
Ich persönlich finde es dann auch manchmal
so bisschen unübersichtlich, wenn man zu viele
Hat.
Also löschen wir jetzt erst mal wieder diese Ebenen und
fügen dann nach und nach die Ebenen dazu,
die wir wirklich brauchen.
Ich klicke also hier drauf und dann habe ich hier
so einen Papierkorb und da kann ich eine Ebene löschen.
Jetzt habe ich wieder eine Ebene.
Diese kann ich jetzt auch ein- oder ausblenden.
Also am besten hast du jetzt noch eine Form,
die du gezeichnet hast.
Wenn du jetzt hier auf das Auger neben dieser Ebene gehst
und draufklickst,
wird die Ebene unsichtbar
Wenn du sperren und wieder entsperren,
also wenn du draufklickst, dann kommt da
so ein kleines Schlosssymbol.
Das heißt, die Ebene kann jetzt nicht mehr
bearbeitet werden.
Jetzt noch mal zusammengefasst,
wie du mit Ebenen arbeiten kannst.
Es gibt verschiedene Tastaturkürzel zum
speichern oder zum löschen.
Die lernst du am besten auswendig.
Wenn du eine neue Ebene anlegen möchtest,
klickst du auf das Pluszeichen im Ebenenbedienfeld.
Wenn du eine Ebene löschen möchtest,
gibt es dafür das Papierkorbsymbol im Ebenenbedienfeld
und sperren kannst du eine Ebene ebenfalls hier,
indem du links daneben auf das Schlosssymbol klickst.
Und da kannst du auch eine sichtbar oder unsichtbar machen.
Neben diesem Schlosssymbol befindet sich das Augensymbol,
das dafür dient.